la sculpture la peinture l'architecturé
la musique tous instance ans dans sa
maison de saint sauveur achetée en 1971
roger taillibert passe beaucoup de temps
dans son atelier à faire de la peinture
la peinture ça se conçoit comme de l'
architecture voyez là ici une tâche
rouge
l'ania du bleu tout ça doit être conçu
ensemble et a semblé alors si la tête
qui fait ça signe des temps pour moi
j'oublie tous les problèmes lorsqu'il
est de passage au québec entre deux
coups de pinceau roger taillibert pense
encore au stade olympique une de ses
grandes réalisations créé pour les jeux
olympiques de montréal de 1976
selon lui le stade est aujourd'hui mal
utilisés qui sert à rien c'est un dépôt
ce magasin c'est la halle de stockage de
montréal toutes les cochonneries on y
met dedans
la carrière de roger taillibert s'est
échelonnée sur 70 ans il a créé
d'impressionnants structure partout dans
le monde dont le stade du parc des
princes à paris ils s'étaient manifestés
pour dessiner le futur pont champlain
il est déçu du projet qui a été choisi
c'est un monument qu'il faut le faire
mais pas par le bricolage de pot pour
moi le poison est un problème très
délicat pour les 93 ans de roger
taillibert un nouveau documentaire fait
le survol de sa carrière et pour une
première fois on expose une partie de
son travail au centre d'art diane
dufresne de repentis pour le co
commissaire de l'exposition alain stanké
il s'agit d'un geste de réhabilitation
feu très bien oui disons que ça très
bien
je pense que oui parce que il ya eu
tellement de fake news comme dirait
temple à son propos il ya des choses qui
sont absolument inimaginable voilà ce
que ce que roger a subi comme injustice
je ne sais pas si à sa place je restais
au québec
ça fait 50 ans qui vit ici 50 ans à un
nouveau titre n'oubliez pas que j'ai été
architecte en chef conservateur du grand
palais à paris pendant 20 ans roger
taillibert a réalisé près de 500 projets
et il espère que ces stats de béton
serviront encore longtemps pour de
grands événements sportifs
c'est la base de la société humaine
c'est la base de nos muscles c'est la
base de notre respiration ici louis fait
déprimer radio-canada repenti
[Musique]